[موسيقى]
قد يكون من ارقى قصور عصر النهضه
شنو صوت تحفه معماريه من القرن السادس عشر
مشيد بدقه في قلبي نهر لوشار وسط فرنسا
يزوره مئه من الاشخاص كل يوم
يحمل على عاتقه فتح ابواب القصر منذ 37
سنه مبنى قديم بارد جدا في الشتاء حار في
الصيف لتهويته يتوفر على 60 نافذه
لابد من دخول الهواء الى القصر لان
الحراره ترتفع شيئا فشيئا في الخارج فيصبح
القصر في الداخل حرا جدا
كل شيء يجب ان يكون في مكانه قبل فتح
القصر امام الزوار
لجعله في ابهى حله توضع به باقات ضخمه
صنعت شهرته عبر العالم باسره يتم تغييرها
كل اسبوع بفضل ابداعات هذين المتخصصين في
تصميم وتنسيق وتركيب باقه الازهار هذه
التشكيله مثلا تزين 30 كلغ
المكان الامثل لها بالنسبه الى جونسوار
وهذه القاعه الصغيره التي كانت كاتخين دو
ميديسيس تدير منها دفه حكم فرنسا قبل 500
سنه تقريبا
كانت الحروب تدور في كل مكان بينما كان
الهدوء سيد المكان هنا انظر الى نهر لوشيخ
كيف هو ساكن وهادئ في جو من الطمانينه
هو قصه امراه قبل كل شيء ما اكسبه لقب قصر
السيدات
صممته المهندسه كاتخين بريسوني في القرن
السادس عشر ثم اثرت بناءه دياندو بواتيي
ليصبح بعد ذلك مكان
اقامتيس التي ستقوم هي الاخرى بتوسيعه حتى
يرتمي بين احضان النهر
شنوسو نغمه تتردد نوتاتها اولا في هذه
الحدائق الغنائه التي يظهر عليها نيكولاس
وزملائه
ستطلب الكثير من العنايه والتجذيب وازاله
الاعشاب الضاره هناك ما يجب فعله دائما
جاء الى فرنسا عام 2015 نيكولاس امريكي
وقع في حب الحدائق الفرنسيه حديقه ديان
مثلا نموذج يحتدى به في تصميم الحدائق
هي من الحدائق الاولى في فرنسا التي صممت
على اساس محاور متعدده نباتاتها واشجارها
مشذبه ومنظمه جدا انها الحديقه الام
لحديقتي
اذا كانت الحدائق محطه اعجاب الزوار
فاروقه القصر تثير دهشتهم كذلك ياتي اليه
كل يوم سته الاف شخص انه اكثر القصور
زياره بعد قصر فيرساي يعد صغيرا عنه كثيرا
لذلك لا يرافقنا فيه اي دليل لتجنب
الازدحام الذي قد يحدث في بعض زواياه
[موسيقى]
حتى نحن لا نتمكن من الدخول احيانا يجب
علينا الانتظار نعم علينا ان ننتظر دورنا
تمتلك هذا القصر عائله منذ قرن من الزمان
لكنها لا تسكن فيه لذلك يمكننا رؤيه غرفه
وقاعاته ال19 تحت اعين فانسون ساهره طبعا
دون لمس من فضلكم شكرا لدينا الكثير من
النحاس بمجرد لمسه نترك اثارا عليه ما
يتطلب عملا يوميا من قبل عمال التنظيف
لازاله تلك الاثار
في الطابق العلوي للقصر نعثر على قطعه
ثمينه اكثر من تلك الاغراض النحاسيه
ادلين وجيسي تعملان على ترميم لوحه للويس
الرابع عشر واطارها الخشبي المنحوت الضخم
بمستحضر من مسحوق طباشير
بغراء حيواني من جلد الارنب
التي لم تكن موجوده اصلا
تضع جيسي من جهتها اللمسات الاخيره على
اللوحه اصعب شيء بالنسبه اليها هو اعاده
الالوان الاصليه للوحه قديمه تعود الى 300
سنه
نقوم بالتدقيق من خلال عدسه مكبره او حتى
بواسطه مجهر للعثور على الالوان الاصليه
لابد من معرفه نوعيه الالوان التي تم
استخدامها في هذا القرن او ذاك
بعد عده اشهر من العمل المضني المرحله
النهائيه لا تقل حساسيه عن سابقتها
[موسيقى]
حسنا
لوحه الويس الرابع عشر المرممه تجد لها
مكانا اخيرا في القاعه الحمراء للقصر
[موسيقى]
احذروا الجهه اليمنى ليست على ما يرام
حسنا لقد وضعناها جيدا
وضعتموها جيدا نعم جيدا
ممتاز اعتقد اننا سنعود لرؤيتها عده مرات
في هذا اليوم
بعد تجديدها بعنايه فائقه يمكن للزوار
الاستمتاع برؤيه اللوحه الملكيه التي تعود
الى ثلاثه قرون حتى يغلق القصر ابوابه عند
السابعه مساء لكنه سيعود في الصباح من دون
شك في ابهى حله بفضل القائمين على خدمته
حتى ذلك الحين سيبيت قصر سيدتي كما في كل
ليله بين احضان مياه النهر العذبه في
سكينه وطمانينه